at some point in life we all have to
decide whether we want to be victims or
victors do we want to be defined by
slights and wrongs ones that are
perceived or real that we suffer at the
hands of others 242 years ago our
forefathers made the decision that kind
of sitting around boom owning our fate
under British rule wasn't gonna get us
anywhere they decided to do something
about it
we're a people who chose freedom and
liberty rooted in a sense of virtue over
despair and hopelessness and with
courage sacrifice and an indomitable
spirit and an abiding faith in God we
want our independence and eventually
created the greatest country in the
world powerful forces in today's
Democratic Party though are at war with
that fundamental understanding of the
American story
in fact many think the founding of our
country was inherently corrupt
and even illegitimate and they've made a
decision to run against that version of
America in the absence of an actual plan
to grow American prosperity and keep us
safe Democrats are embracing victimhood
as a political platform this midterm
cycle Democrat Stacey Abrams is running
for governor in Georgia the miasma of
fear that has created through voter
suppression is as much about terrifying
people about trying to vote as it is
about actually blocking their ability to
do so now what is she talking about
voter registration has reached a record
level in Georgia and there was a 75%
voter participation there in 2016 the
average nationwide was only 55% Abrams
is selling fear victimhood and the idea
of wait illegal aliens voting the thing
of it is the Blue Wave is
african-american it's white it's you
know it's asian pacific-islander
it was made up of those who've been told
that they are not worthy of being here
it surprised those who are documented
and undocumented wait a midnight train
to Georgia here didn't she just use
catch that sounds like it Abrams had her
druthers illegal immigrants would indeed
or are part of the blue wave in other
words be eligible to vote how does that
not dilute the legal votes of American
citizens of all colors and all
backgrounds but it gets worse up in
Massachusetts where a lot of my family's
from and where for years Elizabeth
Warren has shamelessly pedaled the idea
that she is a Cherokee Indian my Aunt
Bea has walked by that picture at least
a thousand times remarked that he that
her father my papaw had high cheekbones
like all of the Indians being Native
American has been part of my story I
guess since the day I was born was she
born in 1985 because I think that's what
she started to tell the story anyway
Warren is trying to play the victim
after years of taking criticism for a
Native American claims Warren with an
eye on 20/20 tried to get this all out
of the way she released an expensive
video starring a DNA specialist what are
the facts say you absolutely have an
American ancestor in your pedigree
some people have questioned my heritage
in my family history maybe they do it to
insult me maybe they do it to distract
from the kinds of changes I'm fighting
for according to a DNA study analytic
analyzed by Stanford's Carlos Bustamante
who by the way works for 23andme the
company's an advisor of that company
warren is possibly one 1024 which is
0.09 percent Native American ok that's
where the scale goes goes like from 0.09
percent to I don't know like everybody
else according to the New York Times
scientists say the average European
American is 0.18 percent Native American
so that'd make Warren less Native
American than the average European
American wait a second Oh what the heck
happen to liberal concerns about
cultural appropriation
I guess that's out the window Warren is
kind of a typical Democrat though here
she's racially obsessed and let's face
it that's just easier that being
factually informed and worse she's
willing to scam the system in this case
play an Indian to get a boost
professionally or in this case
politically and to add insult to injury
her DNA specialist Carlos Bustamante
flatly admitted that he didn't even use
Native American samples for the test
seriously well to make up for the lack
of those samples he used ones from
Mexico Peru and Colombia keep this up
and warm Warren's gonna be claiming that
she's more latina than Alexandria
Castillo Cortes by 2020 well speaking of
Latinos a new migrant caravan from
Central America the second in six months
is now headed up through Mexico to the
United States this week
it already has 1,600 members naturally
Democrats have started their old
narrative about Trump separating
families at the border if only they had
the same concern for Americans brutally
victimized by illegals here in the
United States in the last few weeks two
illegals have had committed vicious
rapes in just in the New York area
one ever Martinez riot Reyes followed a
Nassau County woman home knocked her out
and repeatedly raped her for about an
hour then there's Julio Ayala he sought
to be a member of ms-13 and Ayala broke
into the bedroom of an 11 year old girl
he did not know and raped her on a bunk
bed with her brother below them
meanwhile we hear almost nothing on that
store those stories are so many more
like them from Democrats who at the same
time agonized over non-citizens
overwhelming our Border Patrol when
Lesley Stahl tried to melt hearts with
her family separation narrative last
night the president set her straight
are you willing to reinstitute that
policy you said we're looking at
everything yes again you can't say yes
or no what I can say is this there are
consequences from coming into a country
namely our country illegally I'm not
gonna ask it again the same as Obama
well Donald Trump has exposed the
fraudulent nature of the left's weak
arguments and their weaker narratives
there is a sudden bounce you felt it in
that sixty minutes interview last night
the left is fuming at 60 minutes
actually aired the interview check out
the blogs but he has that extra bounce
in his step in a sense that his party is
now on the rise again following the
Cavanaugh battle you would have thought
though that the Democrats might have
gotten the message that victimhood for
political gain is not a great strategy
it won't work and it hasn't and the good
news is the Republicans may have finally
found their groove they're out selling
the peace prosperity and security agenda
that Trump won on and is delivering on I
don't know in the end I think most
Americans are just smart enough to see
that victimhood is a dead end personally
and politically and that's the angle